what percent of women would you say want
to be wives and what percent of women
would you say are wives I want to hear
from the men
and your experience
carrying on the conversation that's you
right there
I'm choosing to go last I bet a lot
lie to themselves
so I bet it's higher than they think so
I'm going to say about 80 want to be
wives yeah
are wives yeah okay yeah I think I would
I would agree a lot with that I think a
lot of women want to be wives but they
don't have the substance or the skills
to actually support the lifestyle of the
person that they would ideally like to
be with so then they end up with
somebody that is not fully compatible
with and they go out on my
relationship's all right it will it will
last and you know we have our ups and
downs and they have those sorts of
tumultuous relationships that don't
really work out long term but most women
don't have the the skill sets to be
wives to the men that they aspire to be
with and what skills would you say those
are
patience communication I think
communication is one of the most the
most powerful ones because a lot of
women have
in my experience at least have a lot of
self-doubt and they don't they don't
know how to be supportive to somebody
else they don't know how to communicate
powerfully with somebody else in a ways
that
helps their relationship to grow helps
their relationship to flourish and helps
their relationship to be really
effective
do you think women have self-doubt
because I find them to be more
narcissistic than ever
yeah is it is it a fake narcissistic
though because it's like an external
narcissism but an internal I don't feel
good about this I don't feel I'm worth
it no I feel like
I'll just like even at carnival I was
asking like rate yourself one to ten and
they would say ten I'm like
okay and then I'd ask I'd say well
aren't you perfect doesn't that mean
you're perfect she's like well I'm not
perfect but I am and then they'd say
special but isn't it kind of
narcissistic to think you're special
yeah like everyone thinks they're
special like it's been proven in
Psychology that everyone thinks they're
above average yeah I think they like to
FIB a lot to not hurt everyone's
feelings so
I I was single for six years nothing and
then this year I've just started getting
back into the dating game but the ones
who did text back all said the same
thing I would happily be your friend we
never talked again so why say we're not
going to be friends we know we're not
going to be friends
I'm like and and to say Hannah you say
everyone thinks they're above average
when I rate myself I fully give myself a
five
because I don't feel like I'm better
than anyone and I don't feel like anyone
should be better than me probably a four
four yeah are you making yourself before
you're saying no you're definitely more
than a four bro
when it comes to rating what criteria
are we using like are we using what
scale of one or ten in terms of how good
we are as a partner or how attractive
I'm always talking about looks
okay so I'm always just talking about
looks wonderful yeah okay I'll still
break myself for five because hey what
cool I got high but I'm scoring it in
comparison to most most people I've
interact with right
um
again I'm not I haven't even got a full
beard I mean my beard don't connect so
I'm ready I'm out on the market so so I
don't actually think you answered what
percent of women do you think are wives
what percent want to be wives and what
percent are and then I'm gonna let the
girls answer yeah
um I think 100 of women want to be wives
with contingencies a hundred percent you
think the girls in those videos want to
be wives yeah okay with the
contingencies in the sense of like they
want me 10 grand a month what does that
mean yeah
but it's not a real wife right so like
what percent of women actually want to
be wives if you're upset like actually
want to be a wife with what it comes
with in a traditional sense
um I would say be what men want
what was it I think I heard like what
did you say John like I think I said
it's James by the way sorry that's right
um I said 70 I think 70 or 18 and 30
actually I would say 81 and less than 10
yeah I'm going with 25.
254 one and four are wives one in four
always and what percent wannabe
the rest oh you think all girls want to
be I don't think all girls want to be
wives I feel like they want I just I
can't you can't be doing this [ __ ] I
just
yeah 100 it is just like yeah like and
you look at girls Instagrams and like
the way it's like oh you can't you can't
say but at the same time I'm still
sticking in like here's the fence right
right okay okay I'm hopeful
like here's the first we already know
only fans have really made how many
billion from for women but I'm still
like I'm getting closer to the fence but
I'm still on I'm still off the fence I'm
hopeful hopefully I mean I've been
growing up on Christian values so yeah
what about you guys what do you think so
just to be clear are you asking what
percentage of women like want to be
wives in the sense that they want to be
stay at home full-time um not
necessarily stay at home like they want
to be a man to help me I would say
that's the best way to put it I make
money you help me make money yeah and so
whether like some some girls are wives
and the fact they're more like executive
assistant typewives some girls are wives
and the fact you know they're
stay-at-home mom type wives like it's
not it's not a one some some do the you
know like they both get a job you know
and just but but the the key is that
they're submitting to the man oh I think
around 40
40 of women want that or actively know
they want that because most women think
that submission is a bad thing
they think that they they want to be
empowered and they think that submission
means being a man's slave so I think
only 40 of women have that awareness to
realize that like it's not a bad thing
and to the second percentage I would say
10 actually our wives yeah and why do
you say that why is it so little
because nowadays most women like a most
women have this oh I'm a strong
independent woman Vibe where they tell
themselves they don't even want a
relationship in the first place or they
want to focus on their careers of the
women who want to be in relationships
they still think that submission or
femininity is backwards or a bad thing
so I think only 10 of women
actively want that and they have that
yeah it seems quite london-centric as
well like women that that want to be the
boss they want to be the leader they
want to be more career driven Etc and
less sort of alluding to wanting to be
wives are like London has that in
abundance right so more like outside the
countryside it's a little bit different
yeah what do you think
I would say about 25 I'll probably
married I would say about 45 percent
are wanting to be married but and not in
that state yes and the rest are not
interested of being married simply
because
um that divide between being the wife
and being maybe lethargic
and with some women
probably
um prefer to be the psychic because they
feel like well I can just have the fun
bit I don't have to do all the other
bits that comes into a relationship and
it's not because they devalue themselves
but they feel like
maybe some insecurities in himself where
they feel that they are not enough to be
aware so they'll settle for second mess
whenever I can still have the man I want
in my kind of head but just have it on
that kind of tip do you think women want
that long term well being a side chick
yeah
um reality it wouldn't happen in their
head they think it would happen for some
of them
um which is a harsh truth but it's the
reality for some women and I think
because of maybe ongoing heartbreaks or
putting their heart and soul into
someone that they thought they could
trust and build and just constantly
being put down or putting themselves
down and they just think you know what
it is what it is and that's how some
women how some women have come in
reality in society
do you guys think we'll ever see the
pendulum swing back where instead of sex
schools we'll start to see finishing
schools come back
I did the bouquet of flowers real quick
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible